[Music]
lawmakers on Capitol Hill are working to
address an often-overlooked problem
that's hurting our military community
38% of military spouses are
underemployed compared with about 8% in
the economy as a whole about 12% are
unemployed nearly three times the
national rate it can cause huge
financial hardships for military
families Jan Crawford met with two
military spouses and a u.s. senator
pushing for a change she's in Washington
Jan good morning well good morning so
you know there are a lot of demands on
our servicemembers they've got the
frequent moves those long assignments
away from home so we don't always think
about how hard it is on the military
families and it shouldn't be that
difficult so now some lawmakers here on
Capitol Hill are trying to do something
about it is that good Lakeisha coal is a
mother and small business owner whose
husband has served all over the world in
the Marines we relocated six times we've
had about fourteen addresses or address
six moves yes Aaron Ward is a real
estate agent who spent more than two
decades on the move as an army wife fast
forward 19 moves later 819 moves 19 20
and while their husbands served our
country these women made sacrifices of
their own especially in their careers
where frequent moves meant frequent job
changes I waited tables at Red Lobster I
worked at day care centers I've worked
in government contracting I've done
everything from sell insurance to work
in radio so if you were to look at my
resume and see that I've had you know 25
different jobs that doesn't look very
good right like who wants to hire that
person that's not gonna stick around
have you heard that personally from an
employer like are you a military spouse
yeah are you gonna be you know I had
someone say well if someone was to look
at your resume they will assume that
you're unstable unstable yeah because
you've had so many different jobs for
professionals who require state licenses
uprooting your career can be difficult
if not impossible now I've got to put my
business on hold because it's gonna take
me six months to get my license because
I'm you know moving from Texas to
Florida in Florida you know may not
recognize Texas as licenses this
thing happens we know attorneys and
teachers yeah dentures which all
contributes to this reality in a recent
survey 77 percent said being a military
spouse had negatively affected their
careers more than half of the spouses in
the survey said they bring in no income
and nearly half the families had less
than five thousand dollars saved after
years of frustration both Cole and Ward
took matters into their own hands
starting their own businesses I don't
know what I would have done had I not
chosen entrepreneurship as my career
path I probably would still be stressed
the hell somewhere rolled up in the ball
in the corner somewhere when you first
started hearing about some of these
stories what was your reaction just a
sadness that that I hadn't thought of
thought of it before Virginia senator
Tim Kaine represents more military
families than nearly any other senator
the veterans unemployment rate came down
because there was a patriotic desire to
these people sacrifice we should figure
a way that we can help them we have to
create the same patriotic mentality
about these military spouses there are
signs that change is coming with my
signature at the state level Nebraska
governor Pete Ricketts recently made it
easier for teachers who are military
spouses to find employment and outside
groups like the US Chamber of Commerce
host career fairs targeted at military
spouses Kaine is also pushing bipartisan
legislation at the national level
arguing that addressing the problem will
benefit the military in the long run I
have a kid in the military and you know
the brass always tells you that you know
it's the soldier or the marine that
makes the decision to come in but
usually the in reenlistment decision is
made by an entire family we are the
backbone of the military and I think if
we had more people standing up behind us
and saying we believe in you and we're
gonna put the money behind it it's not
enough just to talk the talk we want to
see people walking the walk why is this
such an important issue why why should
we try to fix it I think we should try
to fix it because it is the right thing
to do I like to say we're the heroes on
the home front
you know we're home keeping the kids
together we're the counting we're the
housekeeper you know we're all of these
professions
on a daily basis just so that our
spouses can go to work and serve the
country now Aaron and Lakeisha told us
that the problem has gotten so bad that
more couples are actually living apart
so the spouse can stay behind and work
senator Kaine and his colleagues say
they hope that Congress can pass a law
later this spring that will help fix
that problem Norah Jan thank you so much
I'm glad to see that's being addressed
the service that spouses are involved in
as well and have to uproot their lives
absolutely the sacrifice that we were
talking about with with Barbara Bush it
goes through the whole family